[Musique]
un grand concert à la porte de
brandebourg symbole de la liberté
retrouvée là où passait le mur de la
honte
les allemands se souviennent d'un pays
coupé en deux pendant 28 ans je voulais
partager ce moment historique avec ma
fille raconte cette femme
moment solennel plus tôt dans la journée
les présidents actuels des anciens pays
du bloc de l'est réunis venus déposer
des fleurs sur ce qu'il reste du mur
honorer ceux qui sont morts en essayant
de le franchir
le soir du 9 novembre 1989 le mur de
berlin est tombé
une révolution qui a bouleversé le monde
entier l'allemagne de l'est sortait de
l'ombre
c'était la fin de la guerre froide de la
peur le début de la réunification et de
la liberté mais trente ans plus tard des
barrières invisibles divise encore
nous sommes effrayés par ces murs
physiques et mentaux venus de toute
l'europe
des jeunes ont exprimé leur espoir mais
aussi leurs craintes
elle même originaire de l'allemagne de
l'est la chancelière angela merkel a
rappelé la fragilité des valeurs
européennes
pour tout pilote lotus group en croûte
de la démocratie l'égalité l'état de
droit la liberté doivent toujours être
défendue at elle dit les alliés d'hier
les dirigeants occidentaux brillaient
par leur absence
mais un morceau du mur a fait son chemin
jusqu'à la maison blanche une livraison
pour le président ce n'est pas un geste
contre un mur en particulier mais bien
contre les murs en général affirme ce
représentant de l'organisme au pin
sahibly trente ans plus tard le mur de
berlin appartient au passé mais on n'a
pas fini d'en tirer les leçons